les chér on va parler maintenant
extraterrestre puisque les humains vont
envoyer un nouveau message aux
extraterrestres as-ton une chance enfin
de les rencontrer les extratrest ça y
est JeanClaude Bour qui va venir nous
rejoindre dans cette
ambiance pas su très
inqui est-ce qu'on peut envoyer le sujet
et Jean-Claude nous rejoint c'est
parti si certains sont plutôt sceptiques
quant à l'existence des extraterrestres
d'autres sont persuadés que nous ne
sommes pas seuls évidemment nous ne
sommes pas seuls dans la galaxie une
théorie qui semble prendre de plus en
plus d'ampleur à tel point que des
scientifiques pourraient même tenter
prochainement d'entrer en contact avec
eux car après une première tentative
d'attant de 1977 où une sonde avait été
lancée dans un but bien précis apporter
aux extraterrestres qu'il serait
susceptible de rencontrer un message des
scientifiques aimeraient aujourd'hui
envoyer une autre sonde contenant des
information et des messages destinés aux
extraterrestres ces documents offrent un
aperçu de la terre et de la civilisation
humaine alors les humains vont envoyer
un nouveau message aux extraterrestre
a-t-on une chance d'enfin les
rencontrer merci
JeanClaude merci Jean-Claude d'être avec
nous Jean-Claude spécialiste
extraterrestre éminent journaliste merci
d'être là Jean-Claude d'abord on va
revenir sur vous
d'abord je vous dis tout le temps est-ce
que vous avez déjà des
expériences vous pensez être des
expériences avec des extraterrestres si
oui dites-le maintenant ou taz-vous à
tout
jamais g je sais que toi oui oui moi je
parle la nuit avec des des gens qui
probablement sont direct lignée de ma
famille notamment un soldat de waterlo
qui me raconte la bagarre à la bataille
il était
pas c'est un soldat napoléonien qui me
raconte pourquoi Napoléon on a perdu à
waterlo et ça c'est voilà y a un gars
qui vient de faire chier en pleine nuit
pour te dire attends moi tuimagines moi
il y a un gars qui vient en pleine nuit
me dire écoute je peux dire pourquoi
Napoléon a perdu dis mais est-ce que je
m'en bats les couilles en fait je suis
en train de dormir j'enregistre une
émission demain et toi tu l'écoutes
tranquille toi c'est des expériences de
spiritualité de voilà moi dire com il se
matérialiste c'est Fatou qui se réveille
dans la nuit et qui regarde un
documentaire dire qui regarde la ch
d'hoire tout simplement non je parle
avec des disparus oui mais il y a un H
de lumière c'est quoi non c'est
spirituel mais je vois son cost tu parl
avec qui de disparu tu as pu parler avec
Jean Le Poulin ah bah tiens justement
non tu as parlé avec qui non mais ben je
parle avec des gens de ma famille en
lignée direct voilà c'est j'ai j'ai vous
savez que j'ai des connexions c'est
c'est des c'est c'est ça se matérialise
pas physiquement ilch
aussi autrement il y a des Alcooliques
Anonymes non
maisrad cette nuit cette nuit non mais
ça m'arrive régulièrement je parle avec
des gens qui voilà j'ai été initié à ça
il cro alors évidemment ça ça fait rire
comme les extraterrestres font rire
depuis 50 ansise sauf que des
scientifiques maintenant nous disent que
la conscience notre conscience n'est pas
dans notre cerveau mais qu'elle est
partout comme ça dans l'univers et que
donc quand on est on nous donne
simplement le moyen d'être connecté à
cette conscience donc ce qu'il dit est
parfaitement rationnel voilà voilà
Jean-Claude c'est c'est vrai mais oui
c'est possible bien sûr parce que
Jean-Claude je le crois toi bon mais non
mais c'est vrai pas ouf mais toi tu
parles avec qui toi non mais moi Jean Le
Poulin justement a vu passer
Marie-Antoinette devant chez lui a venu
de l'Opéra et en fait c'est pas toi
pour et parce qu'il croyait beaucoup et
il s'est renseigné et mon grand-père m'a
expliqué parce que mon grand-père était
dans tout ça que en fait le temps c'est
comme des millefeuilles avec plusieurs
espace-temps et on peut très bien voir
des gens qui sont qui étaent qui ét pas
dans notre
ESP extraterrestre non non vraiment non
non j'attends l'homme invisible un truc
comme ça
qui après on on dit c'est moi non
[Applaudissements]
handicapé moi je crois Jean-Claude
vraiment Jean-Claude je crois HUG non
moi parfois quand je dors la seule chose
qui m'arrive mais je crois pas que c'est
des
extratérestes c'est déjà passé à
miconose d'ailleurs mais ça m'arrive
durant l'année c'est que je suis dans
mon lit j'ai ma couette comme ça et la
couette mais vraiment elle se tire tout
doucement je sens la couette et je suis
à moitié endormi et je sens comme
quelqu'un qui met FL sû que c'est pas
Pedro du
Rambo service et il y a personne si la
cette il y a personne et je vois la
couette qui qui qui recule et je sens et
je sens comme un comme un souffle de de
sensualité comment il faut qu'il change
de femme elle lui prend toute la
couverture
mer non je te jure c'est vrai c'est le
seul truc bizarre qui m'est arrivé mais
après je me dis c'est peut-être mon
inconscient toi tu es un ouf toi oui
mais moi il se passe rien de rien de
rien moi je vois que ce que je crois et
voilà et mais rien de rien Raymon toi
une fois moi quoi tu as failli manger un
slip dans un chemin je passe sur un
chemin et je vois deux points rouge
comme ça qui bouge comme ça arrê pas de
bouger ouais arrête pas de bouger comme
ça deux points rouges ça monte ça
descend ça monte ça descend point rouge
je dis au mec à côté de moi c'est quoi
ça il me dit c'est les extraterrestres
non c'est pas point rouge comme ça qui
bougeent en fait il dit non tu sais on
est au bois de Boulogne il était 2h du
ma [__] c'est deux mecs qui fumaient
[Applaudissements]
des de mecs qui fumait des clopes
en on a flippé on a vraiment cru que
c'était ah c'est
extraordinaire alors moi il m'est
arrivéit plusieurs fois de me réveriller
avec plein de bleu sur le corps viment
plein de bleu et du coup je l'ai raconté
sur les réseaux sociaux et on m'avait
dit que c'était un jein
amoureux un jein amoureux un joun les
jenoun ah ouaisoun pr tu les as plus
après genounc c'est qui ça qui un genoun
c'est quo oui un genoun un un un jean un
génie ah ouais un
je fr je sais pas en tout cas ça a duré
Moo quoi et donc ça fait longtemps que
ça t pas arrivé ouais j'avais des bleu
j'avais mal à la bouche
gen je sais pas ce qu' me disait mais
ok
cl pas croiser les deux
mecs
mais oui Bernard monel non moi al moi
moi sincèrement j'ai vu mais là vous
parlez de choses qui sont pas des
extraterrestres ça se trouve hein euh ce
que j'ai vu moi en Espagne il y a très
longtemps quand on était jeune avec mes
frères d'ailleurs on a vu toujours jeune
on a vu des tu es gentil on a vu des des
des des cylindres vraiment qui se
déplaçent à très à très vive allure et
sans bruit mais vraiment plus ENF on les
a vu très longtemps avec mes frères à
tel point qu'on a appelé tout le monde
tout le monde les a vu et c'était pas
normal c'était comme ça et ça partait
d'un sens c'était rapide et cetera
vraiment on a vu ça c'est tout euh et
toujours pas d'explication oh non aucune
alors le lendemain ils en ont parlé dans
les dans les journaux télévisés de en
Espagne à marbea et aucune explication
ils ont dit effectivement ce phénomène
que tout le monde avait repéré tout le
monde a vu mais vraiment c'était des
cylindres qui ont bougé dans tous les
sens dans le ciel oui ausul ils ont été
ils ont été stagnants et puis après il
partaient très vite ils revenaient ils
redescendaient et c'est resté vraiment
10 minutes vraiment 10 minutes on a
vraiment eu le temps de les voir voilà
c'est tout ce que j'ai comme expérience
ça ça c'est quoi Jean-Claude ça c'est
ben sa description qui est parfaitement
claire correspond exactement à des
centaines de milliers de témoignages
d'observateurs qui ont vu quelque chose
qui ne rentre pas dans le cadre de ce
que nous pouvons expliquer qu'est-ce que
c'est que ces cylindres qui ne faisaent
pas de bruit qui partaiit d'un coup à
gauche d'un coup à droite qui descendait
et cetera on sait pas ce que
c'est fa la
maar estce qu'on sait pas l'expliquer
que c'est paranormal c'est peut-être
parce qu'on est pas encore à un niveau
de science pour expliquer les choses
Jean-Claude voilà il a tout dit bravo
Jean-Claude benï euh moi je crois que
j'ai vu une boulette volé non alors au
Maroc les genouous on en parle beaucoup
parce qu'effectivement moi par exemple
il y avait une pe une nounou qui
s'occupait de moi qui dormait à la
maison quand j'étais toute petite
j'avais 3 4 ans et qui disait à à ma
mère que le genoune venait la visiter le
soir et on disait mais non mais
n'importe quoi et cetera et
effectivement quand elle se réveillait
le matin elle avait des Bleus partout
donc ça c'était une histoire qui qui
voilà et et moi j'ai moi je crois aux
anges gardiens et parfois j'ai le
sentiment qu'il y a quelqu'un dans la
pièce mais bienveillant et je me
retourne il y a personne mais mais comme
une enveloppe protectrice voilà
ouais s papa to en
slip avec des bonbons oui j'is non mais
il y a une dizaine d'années à l'îedieu
un soir on avait fait un pique-nique et
on avait c'était pas à la mode encore on
avait mis dans jeté dans le scène vous
savez les les lanternes thaïlandaises
avec une voilà qui se déplace comme ça
et c'est magnifique qu a plein mais là
il y en avait qu'une comme ça qui est
qui est partie on était se couché et le
lendemain qu'est-ce qui se passe on
regarde dans le journal un
extraterrestre détecté à l'idiot et
cetera des gendarmes qui sont venus on
avait fini par être obligé d'aller au
commissariat enfin la gendarmerie pour
dire qu'en fait non CIT pas un extratest
parce que il y a carrément des experts
mais je vous apporterai la coupure du
journal ah ben si non non alà je je la
retrouve sur sur sur le non ben al là
par mettez un billet de 100 balles tu
vitéenfire rocherot non à l'époque ouais
vas-y donnez-moi 5 minutes attends va
t'interroger
d'abord Raymon geréraline g s'il vous
plaît les enquêteurs c'était en quelle
année exactement je je prends pas des
notes une petite dizaine d'années voilà
c'est tout d'accord tu étais avec qui à
l'îedieu exactement donne les noms les
prénoms compte à 30 mon petit
bonhom il se trouve que la mère de ma
fille a une maison l'îieu depuis très
très longtemps sur la plage des vieilles
ça tu connais pas j'imagine voilà et
donc c'était sur une plage la plage de
des corbeaux je crois on était
ça exâ des corbeaux à l'île DIU oui oui
bah vérifie vérifie tuas internet s'il
te PLA vous aviez été interrogé par qui
le lendemain on n pas été interrogé mais
il y a des gendarmes qui s'étaient
déplacés du continent parce que l' éta à
1 heure de bateau de du du la rive pour
pour venir constater prendre prendre ple
nuit les gendarmes ont pris un bateau
pour venir ils sont venus le lendemain
ils sont venus le lendemain oui parce
que c il faut savoir que en
1974 quand j'ai réalisé la première
interview d'un ministre d'État chargé de
la défense nationale Monsieur Robert
Galé des instructions ont été données à
l'ensemble des gendarmeries un an et
demi après pour que des enquêtes soient
faites quand il y avait des observations
devenir parce que les gendarmes ont vu
eux-mêmes des objets volants non
identifiés avant 1974 date de cette
interview et que le GPON a été
créé
connard Deo c'est toi qui a écrit
l'article là ça va trop
loin ça t'est pas arrivé à toi c'est un
truc qui tuétais quand quand tu étais
journaliste on te l' raconé c'est pas
toi non non non non dis est-ce que c'est
toi ou pas c'est pas toi toi mais tu
l'as lu dans la
Press
qui
jeanmich
Jean-Michel vous arrê de mentir ah bah
oui évidemment je suis journaliste
j'aiécris un papier mais il y a d'utes
PAP ah ouiuse ah oui ah oui excusez-moi
d'avoir un
métier écr l'ticle mais c'est
pas arrivé à des g c'est arrivé à des
gens mais pas à toi tu t'attrib dis la
vérité oui c'est
vrai
[Applaudissements]
crich je te jureain mais est conis pas
j'avais éc un papier non mais je savais
pas que j'avais écr un papier donc en
fait par cet article tu voulais tu
voulaismtoire est vrai l'histoire ça pas
arrivver mais l'ire est vrai que des
gens ont cru que c'était un OV VO donc
tu voulais démontrer quoi en disant ça
et ben que des gens pensent voir des
choses et en fait c'est pas toujours la
vérité pourquoi tu dis pas ça au lie de
dire
% Jean-Claude qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
en en
77 on on en parce qu' a ce message si S
passé qu 77 l'agence spatiale
des c'est quoi dis
d' l'agence spatiale non mais s'est
passé quoi 7 spaal des États-Unis envoy
des de comme des disques d'or des
messages dans l'au-delà c'est vrai
c'était les sons voyageurs 1 et de les
sons qu'on a envoyé en 1977 cétait le
premier message vers les
extr a quoi c'est le premier message
qu'on leur envoy il y avait des extraits
de
musique le premier message date de
1962 ce sont les soviétiqu qui l'ont
envoyé du côté d'une planète du système
solaire il y avait trois mots
il y avait URSS enfin
CCCP en cidique et puis il y avait
Lénine et et puis il y avait bonjour
bonjour les
extraterrestres et ils ont jamais
répondu les extraterrestres trop ils on
ils ont lâché un vu quoi je ne vous
entends je ne vous entends pas les
extraterrestes n'ont jamais répondu en
fait parl desm non mais là là Cyril vous
posez parfaitement bien la question
c'est que on envoie des messages en
disant é ne nous répond pas mais d'abord
quelle langue parle-t-il si tantz qu'il
parle une langue parce que beaucoup de
témoignages de cas d'atterrissage nous
montre que des extraterrestres
communiquent par la
[Applaudissements]
pensée donc c'est la première
question dans quelle langue
commande-t-il alors je peux vous donner
un scoop c'est que en ce moment même à
300000 km par
j'ai envoyé moi un message aux
extraterrestres qui est parti en 2005
non il arrive quand par les antennes du
ah ou il va arver qu c'est la chaîne
culturel Arté qui m'a demandé d'imaginer
un message aux
extraterrest
faoutre je je l'ai envoyé
alors iludrait mieux pas parce
qu'
donc
ce vers C globulaire il est pas encore
arrivé le message il est pas arrivver
non non il arrivera dans 25 ans ouis et
vous l'avez envoyé Parel par quel moyen
c'est quoi c'est les antennes du
d'accord c'est un message on et et le
message il était très simple c'est un
message mathématique parce que je pense
que le langage universel il est
mathématique donc j'avais pris des
oranges j'ai pris une orange lesai
montré à la camérais deux oranges au
placard puis quatre oranges puis h
oranges et je me suis arrêté à 16
oranges mais il il est
épicié il fait alors je ne sais pas
s'ils pourront le décoder et si quel
c'est que des oranges j' m envoyé des
oranges av des photos des extrait de
musique parce que c'est plus facile à
tenir AHC
oui oui là de dans les disques d'or là
il y avait des photos d'humains
d'animaux pour les habitués s'ils
viennent nous voir et comment ils vont
les lire bah c'est un peu une bouteille
c'est une bouteille à
c'est une bouteille à la mer c'est ils
essayent ah ouais donc d'accord ah ouais
et alors c'est quoi ce message qu'on va
envoyer alors on va envoyer un un un
message aux extraterrestres donc les
humains vont envoyer un message pourquoi
c'est alors on envoie un message parce
qu'on imagine qu'on est pas seul dans
l'univers et on l'imagine d'autant moins
que grâce à web qui a été lancé il y a
un peu plus d'un an on se rend compte
que l'univers quand on disait l'univers
il y a encore 4 ou 5 ans c'est c'était
l'immensité absolue mais se rend compte
que cette immensité si je ose dire est
encore beaucoup plus immense qu'on de
l'imaginer parce que on pensait qu'il y
avait 50 à 100 milliards de galaxies et
web nous a montré qu'il y avait plus de
2000 milliards de galaxies c'est-à-dire
que l'univers a été multiplié par 20 euh
et puis on en a pratiquement pas parlé
il séend SAU che Anouna posk oui al moi
j'ai une question que je me suis
toujours posé est-ce que si jamais les
extraterrestres ils existent vraiment il
y a une preuve et cetera est-ce que
l'État il va nous le dire ou est-ce
qu'il va le cacher au hum c'est une
bonne question question c'est une très
bonne question parce que vous savez
qu'il y a des scientifiques de très haut
niveau je pense àchet de cet israélien
qui est un professeur d'université qui
est maintenant à la retraite qui est
général de tsal a déclaré qu'il y avait
des extraterrestres parmi les terriens
et que certains gouvernements étaient au
courant c'est ce qu'a dit M vedef le
président de la Russie qui a sudé qui
parmi nous il y a déjà des
extraterrestres oui oui autour de la
table ça se trouve
[Rires]
rtien c'est plus créd les gars s'il y
avait un extraterrestre ici ce serait
qui pour vous Jean-Michel
Gill valnard Gill Gill Gill moi
Gill Gilles ou
Paul ser teress il doit faire des trucs
de ouf que personne peut faire en fait
donc moi je c'est pas pour sucer mais ça
sera
les alors il a pas tort
excusei ex meuê
gar d' extraterrestre tu prends des
bananes avec ta meuf unu excuse-moi
extraterrestre il dort pas par
exemple lui il dort il dort JeanClaude
comment on pourrait reconnaître un
extraterrestre ah ben je crois que c'est
surtout lui qui va vous reconnaître
ouais parce que quand on est face à une
intelligence qui est très différ de lare
mais qui est beaucoup plus évalué c'est
lui qui a la maîtrise du contact ce que
je dis pour reconnaître h débiles autour
d'une table fallait bien que ce soit un
extraterrestre il nous a reconnu et vous
vous sentez vraiment différent non mais
moi moi je pense que c'est peut-être
Gill l'extraterrestreuss bah Gill tu te
sens extraterrestre je me sens ailleurs
je me sens différent pas extraterrestre
mais différent tu es pas juste
con oh non excuse-moi Jean-Claude ils
seront gentils ou est-ce qu'ils seront
agressif
alors les témoignages que nous avons
recueilli quand je dis nous c'est
l'ensemble des des journalistes ou des
scientifiques ou des forces de l'ordre
du monde entier tout autour de la
planète de depuis des milliers d'années
parce qu'on voit des omovnis depuis des
milliers d'années euh montre qu'il y a
sans doute plusieurs catégories
d'extraterrestres ce qui veut dire que
ou bien nous sommes visités par
plusieurs planètes où il y a de la vie
intelligente ou bien sur une planète il
y a plusieurs intelligentes différentes
un peu comme il y a différent th sur la
planète Terre et et et doncjà déjà on
connaitt un l'extraterrestre il a dit
lui-même qui bah Jul ah oui ah oui je
suis un OV dit qu'on l'app l'ovis un OV
mais moi je suis on peut poser encore
une question moi je suis un peu trop
rationnelle et j'arrive pas trop à
comprendre si vous dites que les
extraterrestres sont peut-être parmi
nous en fait ça veut dire qu'un
extraterrestre il tombe comme ça de
nulle part ça veut dire qu'on peut pas
avoir par exemple une maman un papa une
filiation une famille ça veut dire que
tout d'un coup il y a un mec qui
débarque comme ça il a aucun lien avec
personne nulle part c'est possible ça
vous croyez
euh je crois que nous sommes ce que
j'appelle des bâtards du cosmos
c'estd toujours été sympa avec
toi pas mal comme nous sommes des des
sainges amélioré et c'est très bien
décrit d'ailleurs dans les livres dit
sacrés l'Ancien Testament le Coran le
Main barata et cetera dans l'Ancien
Testament on voit bien que il y a une
intelligence qui descend du ciel qu que
qu'on appelle Dieu et et qui dans le
paradis terrestre fait une manipulation
génétique Dieu plongeait l'homme dans un
profond sommeil il pris une côte et puis
il a amélioré le singe de l'époque et
voilà malheureusement le résultat
magnifique Jean-Claude oui Bernard
Montier est-ce que tu crois Jean-Claude
est-ce que tu crois que Dieu est un
extraterrestre oh là je pense que nous
considérons que les extraterrestres qui
nous ont visité sont des anges ou des
dieux il faut lire les
des êtres qui ressembl qui descendaient
du ciel on dit ce sont les anges ce sont
les envoyés de Dieu c'est Dieu non
c'était
une Père Noël il DESC ci vra Papa Noël
quand tu descendras du
cielve m de temp que le jour se lève
dis-moi tu trouves ça normal que le Père
Noël il travaille qu'un jour par
an Jean-Claude j'ai une question plus
personnelle pour vous certains disent
que vous-même vous avez été visité et
que dans vos propos en fait vous êtes
mandaté par les extraterrestres pour
nous préparer à leur venue est'est-ce
que vous répondez à ça du tout non je
réponds pas du tout je suis un
extraterrestre ce qui est très différent
ou là là jeanclud Jean-Claude c'est
juste un mec qui qui qui travaille et
qui étudie étudie truc c'est 50
exactement c'est pas un charlot nous il
dit pas n'importe je REM pas du tout en
cause moi
je tout ce que tu dis je Cisou bien sûr
non mais c'est un scientifique
évidemment je metets pas du tout en C
j'y connais absolument rien vous avez
teur Ciril parce que vous êtes un garçon
évidemment brillant vous avez une
intelligence qui est supérieure à la
moyenne et vous ne devez pas prendre
pour argent comptant ce que quelqu'un
vous dit vous devez je pense que c'est
vrai parce que pourquoi pourquoi
l'analyser le vérifier pourquoi pourquoi
dans tous les pays il y a des cellules
qui sont consacrées avecargent qui est
misargent de l'État aux extraterrestres
a quand même quelque chose c'est vrai
c'est curieux ben moi c'est ça ça c'est
de ça que je parle moi je parle du
principe que quand un état met de
l'argent quelque part c'est qui met pas
de l'argent pour rien c'est pas à Pertre
je vous rappellerai simplement ce qu'a
dit le chef d'état-major de l'armée de
l'air des États-Unis qui n'est pas un
petit caporal chef dans une armée de
sud-africaine euh on lui a demandé quand
il a envoyé son chasseur le plus
performant détruire ce qui était en
janvier 2023 appelé des FO des homes de
volant non identifiés un confrère
américain lui a dit mais mon Général
est-ce que quand vous dites que vos
avions sont allés abattre deux UFO deux
ovenis est-ce que vous conservez le sens
extraterrestre et il a répondu je
n'exclus aucune hypothèse ah ouais
ah ouais fort ouais mais envoyeer des
messages est-ce que c'est pas hyper
risqué parce que potentiellement quoi
desdm ouais envoyer des DM aux
extraterrestres est-ce que c'est pas
hyper risqué parce qu'ils peuvent très
bien avoir envie aussi de nous envahir
puisque c'est un peu la notion de l'être
vivant de vouloir envahir d'autres
territoires donc là on leur dit e oh on
est là et ils peuvent venir pour tous
nous dégommer c'est une très bonne
question que tous ceux qui ont envoyz
des messages se sont posés et dans mon
dernier livre Les ovenis voyagent dans
le temps et le voilà jean-claudat que
j'ai coécrit avec Patrick Marquet qui
est un physicien de très haut niveau
j'adore ce mec euh tout s'explique de
façon différente c'estàd que la question
que vous posez est très pertinente mais
elle est pertinente dans notre
connaissance scientifique à nous
c'est-à-dire de l'année du 1er janvier
au 31 décembre mais si nous voyageons
dans le temps le 1er janvier le 31
décembre est ce qui entre les deux n'a
plus aucun sens puisque je suis capable
d'aller le 25 décembre le 3 janvier le 7
février le 17 juillet et
cetera le 18 et le temps n'est pas le
même ou le 18 oui ça m pourquoi tu es né
le 18 mais je trouve ce qui dessert un
peu la cause parce que moi je vous crois
sur beaucoup de choses non non mais je
demande à personne de me croire mais non
non en tout cas je veux bien c mais ce
qui ce qui dessert le discours je trouve
c'est l'histoire genens qui sont parmi
nous parce qu' alors ils descendent ils
arrivent c'est les petits hommes verts
sans trou ball sans rien ils font claque
il se transformment en humain c'est pas
crédible du tout quoi ça ça dessire la
cause je suis tout à fait d'accord il
faut simplement regarder alors
maintenant avec le téléphone portable tu
tu as vu ce qu'on pouvait faire tout à
l'heure puisque cyril a immédiatement vu
que tu nous faisais une arnaque bien sûr
il faut aller voir mvedef le présid il
était président de la Russie à l'époque
bah il est plus hein oui donc il a été
et il dit oui les extraterrestres
existent ils sont sur la planète Terre
alors la la journaliste qui lui pose la
question elle est morte de rire un peu
comme certains d'entre vous c'est àit
Natur et il dit la première chose qu'on
nous donne quand on est élu président
d'un grand pays comme la Russie c'est
une malette dans laquelle il y a la
liste de tous les extraterrestres qui
sont dans divers gouvernements de la
planète la fille est toujours morte de
rire sauf que le gars il rit pas du tout
il y en a dans not gouvernement à mon
avis
c'est la ministre de la Culture merci
Jean-Claude Bour d'avt AC nous jeppelle
le Liv lesy tempsclaud Bour patri marqu
très intéressant ça et Jean-Claude c'est
vraiment c'est un monstre il est très
fort très beau cade merci on se retrouve
dans un instant avec de la rigolade à
tout
suite